on va désormais piqué à tour de bras à
partir de mardi elle les ados de 12 à 17
ans vont pouvoir se faire vacciner
contre le coc vide 5 millions de jeunes
sera concerné une condition tout de même
que les deux parents remplissent une
attestation spécifique alors les centres
de vaccination sont ils prêts à
accueillir ce nouveau public et cette
population et pas telle envie d'être
vacciné est la réponse du côté d'amboise
où se sont rendus lucas chopin et rémy
carton j -1
la vaccination des 12-17 ans ouvre
demain et si certains sont sûrs de leur
choix
d'autres hésitent encore on a commencé à
l'évoquer j'ai une adolescente de 14 ans
qui semble vouloir être vaccinée elle
oui elle a commencé à y mettre un petit
peu un souhait dans ce sens ma plus
jeune qui a 11 ans pour l'instant non
c'est juste la peur du vaccin je crois
tout simplement
bah j'aime pas trop les aiguilles ça me
dégoûte un peu déjà cette année j'ai
déjà un vaccin à faire donc moi je suis
pas trop vaccin j'ai un peu peur de
faire pour le courant d'un virus ça me
fait un peu de terrain avec mes deux
filles
nous n'avons pas souhaité qu'elle soit
exposé et le fait d'être vacciné protège
de cette exposition
moi ça me paraît important parce que les
gens autour de nous ils portent pas
forcément le masque du coup le fait
d'être vacciné je trouve ça du coup
important du côté du centre de
vaccination on s'adapte pour recevoir
une nouvelle tranche de la population en
augmentant le nombre de doses
disponibles
le son de vaccination a ouvert le 18
janvier et aujourd'hui on est un petit
peu plus de 20000 vaccinés depuis son
ouverture et on passe un cap à partir de
cette semaine pour monter à 2008 sandoz
par semaine avec un élargissement des
horaires d'ouverture mais si les
effectifs humains et les doses de vaccin
sont bel et bien au rendez vous
plusieurs autres aspects sont à prendre
en compte avant d'entamer cette nouvelle
phase il faut juste qu'on est d'une part
un accord de l'agencé régionale de santé
et il nous faut aussi le matériel
adéquat puisqu'on ne clique pas les
enfants avec les mêmes aiguilles que
pour les adultes
donc pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
reçu d seringue pour qui nous permettra
en fait de faire ce genre de vaccination
comme pour les grands les créneaux sont
réservables sur internet
pour le moment les mineurs ne peuvent
pas se faire vacciner en pharmacie